bon on va descendre dans le lit de la
rivière alors petite session de mode
l'art king ouais marcher le long de la
rivière est repéré ce cas et a dû
consentir à leyment davantage c'est
qu'on va pouvoir trouver des objets qui
sont pas forcément magnétique cette fois
donc ce sera original
well aux très basses parce qu'ils ont
ouvert le barrage aller rasta
on
va jouer
aulas est tombé
alors là il ya quelque chose d'étonnant
je sais pas si c'est une chaîne au début
au début j'ai cru que c'était carrément
des munitions sur un bandeau
mais non je pense que c'est une chaîne
et voyez vraiment
une sorte de vieilles plaies barbecue
de cheminée
au
le tire-bouchon
vieilles bouteilles
sympa
bien sûr y'a plein de tessons de
bouteille et où je vais pas les foyers
ramasser pour l'instant le vert c'est
compliqué
waouh elle est belle il ya plein de
trucs ouais et j'ai trouvé des vieilles
bouteilles elles sont superbes
même les plastiques on va les récupérer
oui oui il y en a trop regardé le flacon
comme il est beau
bien que des frigos
way commence bien c'est l'eau ne monte
pas trop vite
il ya des morceaux de d'assiette par
tous au la pile
ça c'est pas bon pour les cours d'eau
encore une fois
ah non moi j'avais cassé qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc
cool
plastoc
une chaussure
avantage c'est qu'on est les seuls à
faire ça et ses patrons céramique wahou
quatre entités de ferraille
bravo belle des policiers
très pratiques comme le chemin mais bon
regarde away ou la chine non
franchement je sais pas si vous savez un
commentaire je croyais que ça c'était du
plastique mais en fait non c'est une
boîte donc elle marque et
fttb
mais bon ouais mais regarde c'est de la
porcelaine ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est un peu tard peut-être en tout cas
c'est pas du plastique intéressante
[Applaudissements]
au regarde
une clé plate
a ici tu devrais hors des choses
au regard ça se passe vite il ya des ya
des dessins de celui commune elle est
une demie fleurs ça soit très anciens
bayane alternateur
ça je crois
c'est peut-être le mécanisme d'une
horloge ou quelque chose comme ça
ouais c'est comme c'est beau
allez casser ou de quelque chose moi je
prends une corde à sauter cas ces choix
n'ont
consacré bord d
une grenade
non on est clairement confrontée à une
grenade
vu le poids n'y a pas de doute donc
première guerre bon là pour le coup on
n'était pas en train de faire de la
pêche à les membres on pourra pas nous
reprocher de de pêcher à l'aimant de
nous dire que ça pourrait être interdit
ce qu'on appelle les démineurs ou quoi
donc ce qu'on va faire nous c'est qu'on
va voir avec la police ce qu'on fait
pour l'instant elle va rester dans l'eau
sagement
donc voilà si jamais vous envoyer un
fait attention
bon allez on continue à ses pêcheurs de
trésors c'est pas une grenade qui va
nous faire peur aux noms
après il ya aussi la théorie qui dit que
si jamais
si jamais vous pêchez une grenade et
qu'elle vous explose vous devenez
automatiquement la dernière victime du
conflit dans lequel elle était censée
être utilisée
donc il y avait il y avait une chance
pour qu'on devienne la dernière victime
de la première guerre mondiale ce qui en
soi pourrait valoir une page wikipédia
un pneu un gros faux d'un pneu ah ouais
c'est sûr ils ont tiré un peu basse a
scellé on avait vu les tractopelles qui
est un domaine qui nettoyait les berges
alors là j'ai quelque chose aussi
donc ça c'est pareil c'est c'est un
klaxon
cette réaction ne s'est pas une mine ses
ressources mais ça klaxonne
oui un terran
ya encore les tractopelles qui
travaillent non sur la berge
alors clairement ça ils ont commencé à
nettoyer en fait ils les agents de la
commune qui sont encore là-bas en train
de couper les branches ayant sorti pas
mal de choses bah ouais c'est cool ça
montre qu'ils nettoient et regarde ce
qu'ils ont sortis
ouais
ouellette impressionnant
enfin on peut garer un malade doit
remonter le soulever ça
on retourne en chantier
tiens mais ya peut-être un double fond
dans l'otan faut voir si c'est un double
pont phan
fah leur genre
chez bosch france
des athées
et elle numéro de série 15 2
propos reconnaissent 2 way du coup c'est
de la triche parce qu'ils ont utilisés
un tracteur pâle pour le sortir donc
nous on n'a pas les moyens et voilà
c'est fait avoir c'est pas très fair
play et regardez ils ont aussi sorti un
scooter
samba
et oui c'était ça les marques de pneus
du pot passive ne s'écoule à ils ont
bien pêcher bien que nous
regarde la balle mieux ça serait de
regarder tu attends là dans le fond à
droite ouais ouais à la barre que toute
la merde semaine s'il y avait des trucs
dans l'eau un parti devrait du coup
voilà vous avez paraphé deux coffres de
machins là bas
toute la plateforme il ya deux jours du
doigt à 0
bon je vous laisse ouais merci
alors
ça et on va sa
tv 2 1 alors qu'on me voit made in
france
intérieur vous avez du cuivre qui est en
très bon état donc ça va le mettre de
côté pris carrément parce que là on a
perdu un élément barbarian et adore
qu'on a commandé un nouveau pearl a
perdu on sait pas trop ce qui s'est
passé mais donc on a commandé un nouvel
élément perdu c'est le terme sur le site
de maisons de la direction un nouveau
barbarian qui va arriver bientôt et on
en aura de nouveau deux mois et merci à
eux du coup ouais un grand merci à eux
vous avez toutes les infos sur nos
aimants en descriptions et vous avez
aussi le code promo pêcheurs de trésors
qui vous offre 5 % sur toute la boutique
qui prend la balle voilà tranquillement
eh bien oui c'est intelligent de se
secouer quand tu es dans l'eau et il est
aussi bête que son maître
aux messieurs qui nettoie qui était très
sympa et donc ceux qui ont sorti pas mal
de choses hein dans le coffre fort est
évident wen qui était vide enfin c'est
ce qu'ils nous ont dit
attention
les manceaux de bons rails et toujours
de tout eh oui
et hop
du cuivre peut-être c'est en cuir ça
normalement dans ce cas au milieu de ces
trucs regard
du cuivre au nom du cuivre du coup nous
sommes de retour de l'autre côté de la
rive parce que l'eau a été encore plus
baisser donc voilà c'est l'opportunité
ici il ya pas mal de choses qu'on voit
de la rive enfin vos efforts ouais j'ai
envie de liste black déjà ça soit en
aimant
et un coup de chaud aussi
aux les lourdes c'est un fardeau direct
deuxièmement je pense
ou si lourd
et ben ali seuls qui te fait mal au dos
plaque arrière de cheminée ouais c'est
pas ouais c'est vraiment affronte
west intérieur de cheminée c'est du
poids
belle trouvaille
du coup le ferrailleur va être refait
ouais enfin nous surtout
au yen roula derrière la france passait
une mobylette entière ah ouais il ya une
roue la nôtre où la fois qu'on peut la
faire à deux elles sont même plus faire
oui et bien ouais on va écrire l'ambré
si elle est encore là je pense que c'est
parce qu elle doit être entre les
rochers mais on peut essayer je ne ferai
pas coincer le grand dessein ouais bon
rappel
entre nous tu tires immobilier ouais je
pense que c'est plus safe la vie des
rochers oh ça va ça va le bush
basta est là il se retourne en france
encore un quand même
alors que les communes avant
françois cau par l'eau et basse c'est
utile
moi j'ai quelques vrais moyens moins
important
encore un
superbe qu'est ce que c'est que c'est
bizarre ans superviseur connais pas ce
modèle
c'est un vélomoteur déjà des pédales
ouais
ben hodges nouveau commentaire moi ça me
parait il ya un pneu là-bas peut-être un
peu l'aventuré ou éléments de chaque
côté
oh oui parfait
voilà
donc là j'ai fait cet objet high as du
cuivre dedans baptiste way un objet en
cuivre cool
ah oui
non carter de scooter
voyez que la partie grosse
c'est pas juste la tige qui aimante et
je crois si une tige est un endroit
aussi l'envoyer medupi côté gauche
j'ai un truc si ça accroche moins un peu
haut mais ça accroche
ou la
voilà
et de ah ouais c'est ça c'est ça qui
inventèrent la justesse à hawija lui
c'est ça ouais bah oui c'est cool ses
concerts ses rouges s'étonnant orange
au
réveil des années soixante dix à
penser à un réveil ou re
bois peut-être
leur ai dit tu m'aimes tu irais du
réveil ce matin dit vraiment abus 70,6
électronique m bah oui
à 70 bref
à leyment t
elle est aimanté c'est un panneau je
crois
attention cassis a écrit as ta
route barrée à aimer l'hiver il est très
beau sur la
whey super-légers s'écoule
à mani khel
on va voilà cette vidéo de pécharmant
touche à sa fin mais c'était surtout du
ramassage sont traçables c'était sympa
de regarder quand le web os puis ça nous
donne une idée aussi des vins des
despotes à ne pas piller ouais c'est ça
quand l'on remontera en soi ou aller
parce qu'on a pu repérer les endroits
qui était assez sale et typiquement là
bas par exemple où l'eau est très basse
et israël avaient péché parce qu'on
regarde en face comment faire ce qu'on
va signaler l'endroit où il ya la
grenade à la police et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche à leyment en compagnie de
la star qui est là bas